で その煩悩っていうのは
またそういう特定の人にある煩悩といったらまた勘違い
この戒禁取というこの煩悩がすべての生命にあるんです
私たちはただやらないだけのことで
心の中にあるんです 何か少々違うことをすればいいんじゃないかな
であるということはわかるのは
誰かが特別に業をやっているんだと
三ヶ月間こもって何か業をやっているんだと
千日行をやっているんだとか
何とか聞いたらすぐあ
それはすごいと 思っちゃうでしょうし
人が私はまあまあ一年間一日一食しか食べてないんだと
一日一食食べるようにしているんだと言ったら
すぐあ これはすごいことだと思っちゃうんですね
ですから この煩悩自体は誰にでもあります
それで何か変なことをすれば
それで解脱できるとと思うことで
その人々は何か変なことをしなくちゃいけないんですね
何か違うことをするということは
新しい行動を起こすことで
それで煩悩を持ってやっているんだから
それで解脱は得られなくなる
特に解脱というものは
戒禁取あるならばまるっきり得られないんです
何のことなく 物事の無常だけ感じていればよろしいかという
もうちょっと何かやらなくちゃいけないということが出てくるんですね
この大乗仏教が現れたこと
原因というのはもう数え切れないほどあるんだけど
この初期仏教の一つ一つ説明すると
その一つのポイントだけ言えるんですね
その場合でも その一つのポイントなんですね
で 初期仏教ではすごく軽々く修行していたんですね
で その中でもある人は何ヶ月かも瞑想したり修行したりするんだけど
ある人は寸前に説法を聞いてもう悟ったっていうことで
もう何のことなくもう楽に生活している
それでまた大胆なことはしない
悟ったんだからといって
別にどうかなということじゃなくて
すごい謙虚で まあ自分なりにそれまた生きてるだけなんですね
だから普通に見れば普通の戒禁取で見れば悟ったんですかと
それはまあすごいんだ
何かオーラがなければとかね
空を飛んでいかなければとかね
ああいう風にこの大胆なことで考えちゃうんですね
お釈迦様の時は子供たちでもね
説法を聞いて悟ったしまったことケースいくつかありますからね
だから悟ったんだから
で 子供は子供だからね
あっち走ったりこっち走ったりするわ
そこでお坊さんたちにうるさいんだからあっちへ行けとかね
追い出されるわ そういうのは別にごく普通にありました
うるさいんだからあっちへ行けとかね
追い出されるわ そういうのは別にごく普通にありましたしね
で そういうことを考えて
やっぱりこのお釈迦様
我々言葉ではお釈迦様にはブッダというし
弟子たちが悟ったら阿羅漢というふうに言葉は変えてるんですね
言葉は変えてるんだけど
ただ悟りは悟りであって
何の差もないんです お釈迦様はある日こう言うんですね
私はすべての煩悩から心を解脱して
今なすべきことは成し終えて解脱を体験しているんだと
私の弟子たちもすべての煩悩から心を清らかになって
なすべきことは成し終えて
今解脱を体験しているんだと
じゃあそこで何が違いますかと
全く同じ言葉で言ってね
私は悟っている 私の弟子たちも悟っている
じゃあ何が違うかというと
違いはこういうところなんですね
私は最初に悟った 道を発見した
それで道をみんなに開いてあげた
解脱の道をみんなに教えてあげた
弟子たちが私が教えた道を歩んで悟った
その差ですよ 私は発見者でしたよと
それだけの差 で そこは大乗仏教では認めてないんですね
だから悟ってない人から見れば
なんかオーラも見えないし
普通の人間で見えるし
おそらく煩悩はそのままではないかと
あるいは煩悩は一分なく見たら煩悩はないことを見えますからね
一緒に生活してみると
確かに人が違うということはわかるんです
わかるんだけど だからといって普通の人間とは何か変に違うかというとそうでもないんですね
よりごく普通なんですね
覚った人は マナとか自分という考え方さえないんだから
他の人よりすごい普通なんです
本当に普通な人っていうのは覚った人なんです
他の人は普通じゃないんです
私は何々者かとか何とかとかそこで威張っていつでも全くおかしい行動を起こしているし
起こしているし ですからごく普通の人だから
でも煩悩もないことはないし
そこで余計な妄想をする人にとっては
おそらくブッダには完全に煩悩がなくなった
弟子たちにはまだ残っていると
そういうふうに勘違いするのも
この戒禁集 何か変なことをやっていないんだから
そこでいろんな変な行などはもう大乗仏教で出てくるんですね
悟りに関係ない行いっぱい出てくるんですね
ただ それだけが大乗仏教が現れたわけじゃないんです
またいろんなもう原因あるんですね
いわゆる私が簡単に言いたいのは
この初期仏教の理解は足らなかったということなんですね
特に天台智厳の分析なんか見ると
もう完璧に理解は足らなかったということがわかります
天台智厳も親切に喋りたい
お釈迦様がおっしゃったことは全部それなりに正しいんだと
それなりには正しいんだ
でも最後におっしゃったことはもう全部最後におっしゃったことだけ事実だよと
本当の悟りだよと 言って何を言うかというと
やっぱりこの一体ですね
法身ですか それを体験することだということを言っているんだから
そこら辺すごい勘違いしてるんですね
説明自体矛盾なんですね
例えばこの法身というね
ダーマカーヤですね 全ての現象
三世界であろうが 六道で六道じゃないんですね
大乗仏教では シャラバカも入って
ボサツ パッチェカ ブッダも入って
ボサツも入ってブッダにも入りますから
次元なんですね その種種類の世界はつくるのはもう法身だよと
でもこの法身というのは
それは誰にもわからないんだと
言って 最後には法身に戻らなくちゃいけない
それが本当の悟りだと
煩悩をなくしただけでは悟りじゃないんだというふうなことをまあ無茶苦茶言うんですね
煩悩をなくしてから ある一体と
ある存在と一体にならなくちゃいけないんだ
お釈迦様は最初からそれ否定
否定してるんですね そこら辺わかってないんですね
何かと一体になるということは
もう解脱じゃないんだと
解脱は解脱だからね 誰かの何かの真理の仲間に入るわけじゃないんです
ですからこの いろいろ理解足らなかったことは明確に見えるんですね
それ理解足らなくなることは
お釈迦様もやっぱりちゃんとわかっていましたし
ですから仏教は哲学的に発展させるなと
それはあくまでも実践論として置いておきなさいと
実践しない 実践のために喋ってるんだと
哲学的に発展したら また意見になってしまって
また同じ輪廻の中に入るようになる
ですから 修行した人はだけ仏教はわかるんだと
一応開論集はそれぐらいにして
次に出てくるのはヴィチキッチャーということ
ヴィチキッチャーというのは疑いですね
疑いですね 疑いが生じるのはまた同じことで
すべてのものは無常であって
現象であって 瞬間的なものだということは理解してないんだから
何者かという疑いはいつでも出てくるんですね
だから所詮我々は知っているもの自体はしっかりしていないんだから
正しくないんだから 次の考え方で前の考え方は変わってしまっちゃうんですね
そういうわけで いつでも人間には疑いがあります
それで修行中でもずっと疑いが働いてきて
悟れなくなっちゃうんですね
修行中でもこの無常であることにしっかりしようではなくて
何かを得よう 何かを得ようとかね
何かになろうという 気持ちが働いているんです
それも疑いなんですね
ウッダッチョっていうのは 9番目のウッダッチョ
心の混乱状態ですね 心とまた常に混乱状態にあるんですね
例えば聞いたりすると心は混乱する
見たりするとまた混乱する
また 見たものと聞いたものは全く別質なものだということはできませんだから
知ることはできませんだから
まとめたりする 混乱するんですね
それは車とリンゴを比べてみようと思うことと無意味なことになっちゃうんですね
比べたっても別に何の意味もない結果になってしまうし
私は見るものも聞くものもよっても混乱する
それで見たものと聞いたものを一体化させますから
そこでまた混乱が生まれちゃうんですね
ですから その混乱状態をなくすためには
やっぱり瞑想するしか方法はないんですね
最後の煩悩はアヴィッジャー
智慧がないこと 無明なんですね
結局その無常であることをわかってないんだから
現象であることをわかってない状態に無明というんです
それから その自然にはわかり得ないんですね
わかり得ることはできないんです
普通に普通の心では あり得ないことと
というわけで すべての生命にはアヴィッジャーがあるんです
アヴィッジャーがあるんだから
他の 9つのサンヨジャナも生まれてしまうんですね
ですから 完全に悟るためにはアビッジャーを取り除かなくちゃいけないんですね
それそんなに難しいことではもないんです
じゃあ少々お休みします
いいですか この説明したこの十種類のこの心の働きによって
まあ人間はこの束縛されて輪廻転生しているんだと
解脱を得られないんだと
ですから 解脱ということを考えると
我々はこの問題として考えなくちゃいけないのはその十種類なんですね
他のたくさんのことを考えなくてもよろしいし
十種類理解できれば まだ他のカテゴリーもまたあります
同じ働き 違うカテゴリーに入れて説明することもあります
今説明したのは番目のスッタンタサンヨジャナということで
いわゆる経典で出てくる十種類
アビダンマではもうちょっと言葉変えて違うサンヨジャナ十種類言ってるんですね
アビダンマの場合も一番目はカーマラーガ
それは似ている 二番目は違いますね
ループラガループラガの代わりにバヴァラーガサンヨジャナと
バヴァラーガ バヴァというのは存在
生きていきたいということ
それもラーガなんですね
そこでパティガ来るんですね
お経では四番目 アビダンマでは三番目パティガサンヨジャナ出てくるんですね
怒りの束縛 それで四番目マーナが出てくる
ディッティが出てくる
シーラッブタ パラマーサが出てくる
ヴィチキッチャーサンヨジャナ出てくる
そこでまた変わっちゃうんですね
新しくイッササンヨジャナ
マッチリヤサンヨジャナという二つ入っちゃうんです
ヴィチキッチャーの次にウッダッチャは消えてしまう
ウッダッチャ消えてしまってイッササンヨジャナ
マッチリヤサンヨジャナ二つ入れちゃう
[笑い]だから言葉三つ違うんですね
三つ違う 経典から抜けるのはループラーがアループラーが
それからヴィチキッチャ
あ ヴィチキッチャ言ってます
ウッダッチキッチャ ループラーがアループラーがウッダッチと三つ消えて
その代わりにババラーがいっさーマッチリ入ります
なんでそうなったかっていうのはちょっと言いにくいんですね
いっさーっていうのはまあ嫉妬でしょうし
マッチリっていうのは物惜しみですね
その二つも怒りに関係あるものなんです
それはそれぐらいで結構
まあ十分ですよ そこでこのサニョージャンの場合は二つに分けてるんです
ウッダンバーギ オーランバーギという名前で
ウッダンバーギというのは除ということで
オーランバーギというのはパということで
叱っていうこと で いわゆる柔らかい束縛と
なかなか消えないもの
頑固でしがみついてる束縛と五つなんですね
柔らかいというのは この経典から見るとシーラッブタ・パラマーサとディッティとパティグマーナですね
預流果になると このディッティ消すとシーラッブタ・パラマーサというこのしきたり
行につかめることと疑いは消えちゃうんですね
いわゆる無常はもうわかったんだから
何か意見作ろうっていうことはなくなっちゃうんです
すごく楽に生きていられるんですね
その人はもう見はないんだから
もう確実にお釈迦様の真理は真理であることはわかってるんですね
それから自由で まあ余計な行やらあーだこーだと引かれることはないんですね
かなり落ち着いているということなんですね
そこで普通の人と考えると
この例えば人間というのは
いくらあの仏教をわかっても
他の宗教で真面目にやってると
ああいいなと思ったりはする
誰か超能力者出たなと思ったら
本当にそれはどういうことかと
何かあるかもしれませんと探しに行ったりする
そういう気持ちあるならば
もう預流果には悟ってないということなんですね
預流果に悟った人だったら
もうすぐそれわかってしまうんですね
ものすごい頭がいいということなんです
で ヴィチキッチャも無いんだ
その三つ それで一来果に悟ると怒りと怒りと間違ったマナではなくてカーマーラーガですね
カーマーラーガと一番目のカーマーラーガとパティグが薄くなるんですね
薄くなるだけ いわゆる預流果になった人にはカーマーラーガがあるんです
いわゆる眼耳鼻舌身対照はもう楽しんでいるんですね
で カーマーラーガがあるんだから怒りもあるんです
美味しいものをすごく美味しいと感じちゃうと
美味しくないものだったらこれは美味しくないんですよと
なんでこういう風に料理作るんですかとかね
ということもあり得るんですね
さらに瞑想して無常をわかったならば
そんなに欲に囚われなくてもいいんじゃないかなというぐらい薄くなるんですね
欲に囚われるのはそんなに意味がないとわかった人には
それぐらい怒りも消えるんですね
同じコインの裏と裏と表だから
不還果になっちゃうと
もう欲に囚われないんですね
それで同時に怒りも消えてしまうんですね
欲はない 怒りはない その人は在家であろうとも出家のように生活しちゃうんですね
欲からもう離れて生活する
で そこまでこのマーナやらパティグやらルーパラーガやらルーパラーガっていうのは
それからアヴィッジャっていうのは
かなり心の中に残っているんですね
で さらに瞑想するとアヴィッジャ飛んじゃうんですね
アヴィッジャ完璧に飛んじゃったら
もうルーパラーガ アルーパラーガ
パティグ 全部煩悩にはもう土台がなくなっちゃったんだからね
で 飛んでしまうんです
そういうわけで 阿羅漢になるまで残る煩悩は除と書いて
で 不還果までで順番に消えるものはこの過
過ですかね  [笑い]一応分けてます
言葉違うかな こちらでは集結中の躍動心理権修正量の価値
可分結って言ってるんですけどね
私が使った言葉の逆なんですね
はいはい 合ってます まあ可分結は
まあ預流果から不還果までです
常分結はもう阿羅漢になったところで消えるんだと
そこで問題はこのavijjaなんですね
本当はavijjaだけに戦えばいいんですね avijja
っていうのは このゆっくりと消えるっていうことなんです
一来じゃなくて 預流果で悟った人にももうavijjaが消えてます
いくらか 不還果になったらまたさらに消えてて
そうやってもう段階で消えていくっていうこと
はい それでこの十二番目に行きます
キレス それまた種類あります
キレスっていうのは煩悩
で 煩悩という場合は キレスという場合は汚れという意味で
心の汚れと言えばどれぐらいありますかと
それはわかりやすくするために
まあ種類に分けてるんですね
それはローバドーサ マナ
ローバドーサ モハ マナ
ディッティ ヴィチキッチャ
ティーナ ウッダッチャ
アヒリカ アノッタッパ
ローバドーサ モハっていうのは貪瞋痴
マナは慢で前説明しました
ケンはまた説明しました
ディッティ まあ疑いまた説明しました
ティーナっていうのは惛沈ですね
ウッダッチャは掉挙 で
アヒリカ アノッタッパは無惨無記ということで
まあ大体ずっと同じ説明ですからね
まあ今説明しなくても構いませんといいます
そので心が汚れるんですね
で 貪瞋痴で心が汚れる
測る 比べることで心が汚れる
それはどうせわかりますね
まあ心理学の世界でも劣等感やらね
優越感やら生まれたらその人病気ですからね
で 心は綺麗に動かなくなっちゃうんです
人と比べるようになったら
もうその人には自由に行動できなくなっちゃう
ですから まあ汚れであることは明確に分かります
あの人は私よりすごいとできるんだと思ったら
まあ自分にはもうそのできなくなってしまって行動できなくなるになります
そういうわけで このマーナは汚れということわかりやすい
ディッティも同じ 何か邪見が頭に入り込んじゃったら
世の中見えなくなっちゃうんですね
自分の意見で行動しようとする
リチキッチャーも同じ
ティーナっていうのは渾身ですから
渾身入ったら心はまた働かなくなっちゃうし
ウッダッチもそれで同じことでね
混乱したら 情動状態だったら病気で働けなくなっちゃう
それでアヒリカのタッパはもう新しく出てくるもので無惨無記ですね
で アヒリカっていうのは恥ずかしがらないというような心の働き
なんか変な勇気みたいなものなんですね
両方 アヒリカっていうのは勇気というよりは
ちょっと昨日はちょっと違いますけど
このまあ恥ずかしいことでもまあやってしまうと
そんな恥ずかしいとは思っていられないんだと
で いわゆる悪いことをしちゃがっちゃうんですね
無記っていうのは怖がらない
それはもう変な勇気なんですね
で やってみましょうという気持ちになっちゃうんですね
そこでまた定義は明確にしているんですね
世の中でやってはいけないことをやってしまう
それは無惨無記なんですね
自分に対しても 他人に対してもやってはいけないということはあります
なぜやってはいけないということがあるかというと
やりたいんですね 人々が
この だから戒律に対しても
人間っていうのはいつでもなんとなくすごい拒絶反応を持ってるんですね
で 人間やりたいことっていうのは
しきたりに戒律に規則になりませんだからね
例えば学校の校則にしたっても
それは一つの子供たちはやりたくない
ものは校則になってるんですね
それで当たり前でどうしようもないんで
それは だから戒律にしたっても同じことなんですね
で 人間がそれやりたいんですね
やりたいことをやってはいけないと決まってるんです
だからそれはもう人間は無明にできてるんだから
人間やりたいということは
どうせ無明から発生する考え方なんですね
無明か煩悩から発生するんですね
怒りから欲から情動から
例えば昏眠が出てきちゃうと
授業中は眠たくなっちゃうんです
本人に聞けば寝たいんだと
それで教える側が寝るなと
授業中は寝てはいけないという校則を作らなくてはいけない
そこでやっぱり何て言いますか
対立が生まれちゃうんですね
ずっとそれはもう避けられないことなんです
対立が生まれることが知って
お釈迦様は命令形で言ってないんですね
幸福になりたければそういう風にした方がいいと
こういうこういうことをする人はもう永久的に不幸になるんだと
そういうふうに言って
もうだからやりなさいと
やめなさいとは言わないんです
出家者には言うんですね
自分たちの弟子だから
私はあなた方のためにこういうこういうことはやってはいけませんと言ってるし
こういうことはやりなさいと言っているし
真面目に自分の心を成長したがる比丘はやりなさいと言ったことは真面目にやるんであって
やってはいけませんということは文句言わずに守るんだと
そこをまたもう現れてきた大乗仏教はまた違うところなんですね
お釈迦様 やりなさいと
またやってはいけないということをまた新しく考え直しちゃうんですね
その考え直す権利はないんですね
仏教はブッダの教えですから
ブッダの教えでお釈迦様がこういうことをやってはいけませんと言ったならば
それは絶対的な権利 お釈迦様にあるんですね
そこら辺誤解してたんですね
で 誤解しただけではなくて
それわかってるんです
誤解したこと それでお釈迦様はその立場から外しちゃうんですね
ブッダの立場から 乗り
いわゆる何といいますか
その場合は 乗り移るんじゃなくて
何といいますかね ブッダの代わりに違う人を
だから人のうちに行って
その人を追い出して 違う人にその家を与えてあげるんですね
あなたは今日からこの家の主人だと
それでその人は自分自分の希望通りにやってくれるんだと
それでこの大乗仏教で一番明確な違いはそういうところで
ブッダはもうブッダでなくなっちゃうんですね
ただの化身になっちゃうんで
化け物になってしまって
本当のブッダはもう天国にいるんだそうで
永遠に その本当のブッダは愚か者にこの化け物の形で
人間の形で出てきて 間違ってる説法しましたと
それでその言葉によって
そのそういう哲学を作った方々に自分なりに何でも解釈解釈できるようになったんですね
なぜかというと 永遠永遠のブッダだから
自分に直接言ってくれるんだと
あるテキスト読んだところで
このそういう瞑想すると
この永遠なブッダが自分の耳に教えてくれるんだと
それで今までの経典の意味ではなくて
違う意味がわかってくるんだと
ことを言ってるんです
で なんでそういうことを言ってるかというと
瞑想するといろんな音を聞かせて聞こえたりはします
それを本気で取っちゃうんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想では
聞こえる音なんかはもうただの幻覚ですから
もう全部捨てちゃうんです
全ては無常だから 耳に聞こえる音にしたっても
耳でなく突然聞こえる音にしたって同じ働きだと
そういうものにもとらわれないんだと
ということは理解しますけどね
でも 執着の瞑想だからね
やっぱりこれは本当の教えだと
耳に今自分に聞こえているのは
頭の中に今聞こえて響いている音は本当の教えだと
そういうわけで 大乗の方々
瞑想すると体験様々で
サティルの説明は様々で似てないんですね
それ見つけるのは間違ったポイントで
いわゆる そこで中村先生でもいつでも書く時はすごい先生らしくないんですね
保守的なもう何々仏教と開放的な大乗仏教と
まあ初期仏教とやら上座部仏教やら保守的じゃないかとね
それは証明しなくちゃいけないんだけど
そんな言えん はずなのに
大乗仏教もすっごい保守的なんですね
自由じゃないんです 私たちにある自由は大乗仏教にはまるっきりないんです
きれいに束縛されていて
全部決まり決めつけちゃって
その中で考え方まで釘を打って考えるなと
こういうシステムだよと
大日如来というバカ者がいて
そのバカがもう全部作ってるんだと
あんたはやがてその人のところに行かなくちゃいけないんだと
行ったらまた戻ってくるんだと
単なる輪廻を教えてるんですね
脱出はないんですね だから証拠なしに喋る形而上学的なこと
あの世の世界のことを喋ってるんだからね
人には信仰するしか道がないんです
信仰すること入っちゃったら
もう自由意識はもうそこで消えているんですね
そこでもう無明の始まりで
さらに無明が強化していっちゃいますけど
ですから保守的なんですね
本当のところは だから私たちにある自由はないんです
すっごい厳密にものすごい厳しいんです
それなのに学者は平気で初期仏教やら仏教やらそれはもう保守的な
そういう学者に浸っても固定概念で
日本で書くんだからね
お金出してくれるのは大乗仏教のお寺から出してくれるんだから
その言葉だけ入れてあげれば機嫌を取るだろうと
それによって影響的に学者が研究しても
迷いはそのまんまに残っちゃいますからね
だからずっとそこで学者らしくないところはもうあります
だから他の誰かが保守的って何ですかと具体的に研究すればよろしいんだけど
誰もそれ勇気がないんですね
で 戒律の場合はですね
その保守的だというのは
初期仏教からこの戒律変えてないんだから
そのまんまだから そこは我々に自由がないんじゃなくて
もうお釈迦様のうちに行ったらお釈迦様がしきたり決めるんであって
学校に入っちゃったら
その学校の教える側がしきたり決めるんであって
生徒が決めるんじゃないんです
何時に学校に行くか 何時に学校が終わるかとかね
授業は何にするかとかね
生徒が決める決められないでしょうね
勉強するために行ったんだから
私は日本にいる限りは日本の法律に従わなくちゃいけないし
私は外人だから自分の国の法律に従ってやりなさいと言っちゃったら
政府は何言うかと あんたは帰りなさいと
自分の国に ただそれだけなんです
ビザ発行する時の条件の一つは
日本の法律は厳密に守ることをやって
日本にいるんだったら日本のしきたり守るんであって
それにはもう権利がないんですね
権利があるところ私に選挙もできませんだから
私も投票したいと思ったって
あんたもう自分の国に行って投票しなさいと
それで私の権利を奪っているか全然奪ってないんです
それは当たり前のことだから
この国の人間じゃないんだから
だからブッダがじゃあ私は方法を教えますよと
じゃあ教えてくださいと言ったら
じゃあその戒律じゃなくて違う戒律をしてくださいと
そのやり方じゃなくて違うやり方しなさいという権利はまるっきりない
だからそれは当たり前の常識なのに
お釈迦様はいつも言うのは
やっぱり教えたことは変化してはいけませんと
できませんだからね いつでも私は奉仕であると
私は先生であると 教えるのは私ですよ
しっかりしているんです
それに反対して行ったということもありますね
自分好きなようにやりたいと
悟ってない人は自分好きなようにやりたいということ自体も間違っているということでしょうし
で悟ったんだと それから私
好きな通りにやりたいということはまたありえないんですね
お釈迦様おっしゃった道でたどって
私はもう完全に悟りましたと
じゃあこれからあなた言うことじゃなくて
私は違うことを教えるぞということが成り立たないんですね
そういうわけで この 悟ろうとか励もうとか
そういうことをしないで
その前に先生に上京に行ってしまったんですね
いまだにその行動を同じことで瞑想指導する人が上京に行っちゃったら
その人はそれでもその一生は失格なんです
できないんです いくら頑張っても
わがまま言ったら何度か言ったら
この無惨無期の説明ではよく